so I'm afraid I'm a size I traumatize my
poor son this morning they were there
was a bee that flew up onto the porch
and was on the window and the twins were
arguing they were looking at the bee and
they were arguing with each other about
whether or not it's a boy bee or a girl
B and of course my daughter saying it's
a girl be my sum of things it's a boy B
and so I told them that no it's
definitely a girl B because boy bees
they don't leave the hive they don't
have stingers they just they hang around
the hive all day they don't do anything
that's what boy bees do and my son was
was very upset by this he was in tears
and then my daughter proceeds to chase
him around the house saying you're
you're just like a boy B you don't do
anything girls do everything so I bring
up that story just just to show you that
you may think I'm not enlightened and
that I would never raise a feminist but
in fact I am as you can clearly see I'm
speaking of feminism so I happen to see
on Facebook yesterday this video and
it's it's last I saw it had like 18 or
20 million views on Facebook in just a
couple of days then 70 or 80 thousand
retweets on Twitter and it's about it's
it's by a woman and I think her name is
the Linds and it's meant to sort of mock
and satirize all the people who are or
saying that that now is a scary time for
guys because of the prospect of having
your life ruined by false accusations
well Linds like all feminists thinks
that it's hilarious that anyone would
have any sympathy for guys whatsoever
the idea that it's a scary time for guys
while she finds it and like she and all
the other feminists they they find it
completely hilarious so she wrote this
song airing her grievances talking about
how hard it is for women all the things
that women can't do because they're
women as opposed to men who can do
everything so I can't play the song for
you but I will and I will do you a favor
and I won't sing it for you so instead
I'll just read you some of the lyrics
just so you can understand what it's
about because this song
resonating quite a bit with a lot of
people so some of the lyrics it's a
little spoken word poetry here for you
the song says I can't walk to my car
late at night while on the phone
I can't open up my windows when I'm home
alone I can't go to a bar without a
chaperone and I can't wear a miniskirt
if it's the only one I own tell me about
it I know the feeling I can't use public
transportation after 7 p.m. I can't be
brutally honest when you slide into my
DMS I can't go to the club just to dance
with my friends and I can't ever leave
my drink unattended but it sure is a
scary time for boys
yeah gentlemen band together make some
noise it's really tough when your
reputations on the line and any woman
you've assaulted could turn up anytime
what else okay I can't I can't live in
an apartment if it's on the first floor
I can't be wearing silk pajamas when I
answer the door I can't have another
drink even if I want more I can't make
you feel invalid unseen or ignored
I can't jog around the city with my
headphones on my ears I can't speak out
against my rapist after 35 years I can't
be taken seriously if I'm holding back
tears and I can't ever speak earnestly
about all my fears okay and in fairness
the song is catchy er than it sounds
will you just read the lyrics it's a
it's a it's a you know it's a it's a
catchy little tune and I would even say
it's a clever song but it's also
completely wrong and cynical and
manipulative and dishonest so let's go
through this all the claims all the
things that she says she can't do and
and this is she's just echo this is kind
of the feminist talking but she's just
putting it all to music she said she
can't open her window she can't walk to
her car late at night she can't go to a
bar without a chaperone she can't wear a
miniskirt she can't be brutally honest
she can't dance with her friends she
can't leave a drink unattended she can't
live in a first-floor apartment she
can't wear pajamas when she answers the
door she can't jog with earphones in she
can't make feel somebody feel ignored I
don't know why that has to do with the
other things but that's what she can't
do well here's the thing
first of all if she really can't do most
of these things that's a reflection not
of her gender but of where she lives
if you really can't do any of those
things safely where you live then you
should move if you can you should
definitely move because that means it's
basically unsafe for you to live a
normal human existence and if you have a
choice I would definitely say go find
somewhere else to live if you can't even
open your own windows or go for a jog
then you just live in a very unsafe
place and you shouldn't live there but
here's the important point if it is an
unsafe place if it is such a violent and
crime-ridden place so violent and crime
crime crime ridden that you can't you
have to worry every time you answer your
door you can't open your windows so on
and so forth then that means it's also
unsafe for men if it is statistically
unsafe for a woman to open her windows
in a particular part of town then it's
also unsafe for men we're not
bulletproof okay we're not superheroes
we also we can also be hurt and killed
and we are all the time the statistics
show that in fact men are at a greater
risk of being the victims of violent
crime than women so we also would have
these same concerns if we lived in a
really unsafe place yet I think we all
know that even though she's listing all
these things she can't do we all know
that she probably does almost all of
those things all the times you're saying
I can't all these things she's saying
she can't do she almost certainly does
most women do women wear miniskirts all
that what does this women can't wear a
miniskirt what are you talking about Am
I am I just seeing things I mean am i
imagining this it seemed as though women
make wear that kind of stuff all the
time
women can't dance with their friends I
don't know why I feel like that's
something women do all the time women
can't open up their windows my wife
opens up the windows in our house all
the time should I be telling or not to
that you can't wear pajamas when you
answer the door well I I mean I I think
that you should probably you it's it's
just it's good decorum to not answer the
door in pajamas I I feel like I mean I'm
I'm I'm a pro you know I'm not a
I'm a I'm a pajama critic I think
pajamas belong at night in the home when
you're sleeping but at that but then you
take them but then you put on regular
clothes after that that's that's my
feeling you don't go out in public in
pajamas and I would answer the door but
um I'd rather to be wearing regular
clothes but I don't even so you're
you're worried that if you answered the
door in pajamas
you'll be assaulted can't live in a
first floor apartment well women would
live in first floor apartments all the
time I lived with my wife in a first
floor apartment we never even we never
worried about it we never even thought
about it it was a safe area I see women
jogging with headphones in all the time
in my neighborhood all the time it's a
perfectly normal thing as far as making
people feel ignored or invalidated I
feel like women can in fact do that i I
feel as in fact I I think that women do
that to each other quite a bit but the
rest of it though if you live in a
reasonably safe area
it's perfectly fine with a few
exceptions you know it's a good policy
not to leave a drink unattended it's a
good policy not to have another drink if
you've reached your limit it's a good
policy not to walk to your door to your
car late at night through a dimly lit
parking lot while on the phone because
you should have situational awareness
and you should be aware of your
surroundings so that's a good policy for
everyone men and women included again I
remind you men are not bulletproof we
can also be mugged and killed and shot
and again we are all the time happens to
men all the time it happens to men more
frequently than it happens to women so
what is the point of a song like this
what's the point of when feminists do
this in general what's the point of
painting this picture where women can
barely leave their homes without being
killed or kidnapped well we see what
with this song first of all the first
point is to make a straw it's just one
big straw man argument it's it's to make
a straw man out of the concerns that men
have the way that she reconfigures it is
that men the thing that we're worried
about his men the thing that men are
worried about is that is that they can't
rape anyone and get away with it that's
how she has that's how she has
interpreted and that's how feminists
general are interpreting the concerns
that men have well of course no that's
not our concern our concern is that we
will be accused of doing something like
that even though we have not done that
thing that is the I don't why is this so
difficult to understand what's so hard
about understanding this
that's the it's not about we can't get
away with it it's about we could be
accused of something we didn't do I feel
like am i speaking Greek I think I'm
speaking English it's it should be a
pretty easy thing to understand that's
the concern it does happen and so men
are worried about it if every reason to
be worried about it worried about it
especially because we are told believe
all women so that means that all it
takes is for a woman to tell a story
about us and we're finished that's all
it takes
because you're the one saying believe
all women that's the scary thing but
beyond that I think we see here the the
ugliest and most cynical aspect of
feminism on full display because it
operates on division and fear it wants
to make women afraid of men on one hand
and then also on the other hand it wants
to make them resentful of their own
children that's the other goal of
feminism so you see how you see how
isolating not that this song had nothing
to do with that part of it but this song
is making women afraid of men and then
also the other part of feminism is
resenting your own children so this
feminism has this isolating effect I
think you see how it isolates women it
divides them from men and from children
so from everyone and it's no wonder that
feminists are bitter because it's a very
isolating thing to be a feminist they've
been in
into this worldview that tells them that
everyone is out to kill them or steal
their autonomy that's how they see the
world men are rapists children are
parasites
what a horrible way to live what what a
again it's no wonder that feminists are
so miserable and bitter and angry think
about living that way think about going
through your life seeing the world that
way seeing people that way it's a
horrible thing another point and I think
this is this is worth mentioning if
you're really worried about your safety
if you're worried about answering your
front door or walking down the sidewalk
there is something else you could do
well number one like I said you could
move if it really is unsafe if you don't
live in an unsafe area and you have all
those concerns you feel like you can't
open a window walk down the sidewalk
then I would say you probably need some
medication you're extremely paranoid but
when it comes to more reasonable fears
and we all have certain fears and you
could have reasonable fears or you could
want reasonably to take certain
precautions when it comes to that well
here's another idea get a gun and a
permit to carry it see this is where
this is where the Train kind of derails
for leftist because on one hand they try
to instill this fear into you whether
it's through something like this or when
they tell you that there have been
whatever 600 school shootings in a year
you know when there were there when they
are cynically and dishonestly inflating
the statistics of mass shootings and
they're doing all that the idea is to
make you afraid so they do that but then
they also tell you you don't need a gun
so they tell you it's unsafe to open
your front door it's unsafe to go out in
public because it might be a mass
shooting but then they'll laugh at you
if you even suggest that perhaps you
need a gun so which is it I feel like
you got to choose between those two
narratives either it's insane to buy a
gun and nobody needs it or we live in an
incredibly dangerous violent world and
and if you even crack your window open
somebody might sneak in through it
and murder you like like it's it's
really either one or the other right you
can't do both um final thing I'll say my
I don't I'm not my point here is not to
completely dismiss the concerns that
women may have I fully admit and I agree
that women have to be more cautious in
certain situations than men do women are
more vulnerable in certain ways and in
certain situations I fully agree with
that I don't like for my wife to walk
across a dimly lit parking lot at night
if we can help it by yourself if someone
has to go walk the dog at night take the
dog out in the middle of night I'm gonna
be the one to do it
even though we live in a safe area but
but still I'd prefer for it to be me if
someone has to go check on a strange
noise in the middle of the night well
I'm gonna be the one to go do it if
there's someone we don't recognize
knocking on the door we'll all be the
one to answer it even though you know
99.999999% chance everything will be
fine but still if if if one of us does
have to encounter you know someone who
means us harm it would be better for it
to be me because I'm the bigger and
stronger person right but the problem
with with with the kind of rhetoric in
this song and the kind of rhetoric from
feminists generally is that it's
absurdly exaggerated for one thing so
they greatly exaggerate but for another
the feminist who makes this case does
not believe that men should step in and
be in that protector kind of role the
conclusion they want us to draw is that
men are horrible rapists that's what
they want us to that's what they want us
to conclude but the conclusion that we
should draw is that there are bad people
in the world yes and women are less
physically capable of warding off those
bad people especially if they're unarmed
because they're not as strong and
they're not as big therefore men should
be ready and willing to step in and do
that that's the conclusion we should
draw that's the right conclusion
but that's exactly the conclusion that
feminists don't want you to come to see
whatever glimmer of a legitimate point
might be buried underneath the feminist
rhetoric like this when they talk about
the fears and concerns that women have
there there is there is a there is a a
certain morsel of truth to what they're
saying but the problem is is that it's
buried under so much exaggeration and
then also under so much resentment for
men that it just destroys whatever value
it might have because they are insistent
that whatever happens we must not resort
to anything that resembles traditional
gender roles and and it's that
insistence on their but it's the
insistence that we cannot have anything
that's close to traditional gender roles
where men are being protective or
anything can't do that also by the way
can't have gun rights so it's it's it's
when they do that that's what destroys
us what makes all of this it just makes
it pointless it destroys the point
they're trying to make and by the way it
also hinders any possibility of of
coming up with a practical solution like
when they talk about all the fears that
women have even if it's exaggerated and
all this stuff and then you say okay
well then what should we do about it you
know so okay let's take that then maybe
maybe you should look into how to do you
know self-defense maybe you should avoid
this or that situation like let me I'm
going to take your concern seriously
here are some things that can be done
potentially to make you safer but the
moment you do that they shot all your
victim blaming no victim blaming the
only thing they want to hear is well
then go tell men not to be rapist that's
what we should do that's that's the
solution is to teach men not to rape
which is the stupidest thing it's stupid
because number one the vast majority
men are not rapists so they don't need
that lesson they don't need to be told
that and the men who end the small
minority of men who are rapists they
aren't going to stop just because we
tell them it's it's not like they're
rapists because of a misunderstanding
okay they didn't become rapists because
nobody ever told them not to rape that's
not the issue here so teaching men not
to rape is a completely pointless stupid
thing to say because it's irrelevant to
the men who have no interest in raping
and would not rape and it's also
irrelevant to the actual rapist because
they know they shouldn't be doing it yet
they're doing it anyway because they are
evil bad terrible people so the question
is we know there are evil there are evil
bad terrible people out there that's
just a fact of the matter and we can
scold them for being evil we can try to
re-educate them all we want it's not
going to make a damn bit of difference
so then we have to say to ourselves men
and women we have to say what can we do
to reasonably protect ourselves from
those kinds of people and I think men
should do this too let's flip this
around for a minute I would say the same
thing to men when it comes to false rape
accusations false rape accusations are
terrible they're unfair but I wouldn't
say well we have to teach women not to
do not to make false rape accusations
the women most women would never do it
anyway but the small minority of women
who would resort to that they know they
shouldn't do it so there's no teaching
them not to they know they shouldn't yet
they do it so recognizing that reality
there are certain things that that men
should do and it's not victim placing of
blame on on on the victims of false
accusations to say that but men should
be careful about the situations that
they put themselves in so that they can
insulate themselves from the possibility
as much as possible a false rape
accusation so this is something that
everyone should do and if you're not
interested in talking about the steps
that we as individuals can take to
protect ourselves if you're not
interested in talking about that then
why why did you even bring up the
subject that's the question all right
thanks for watching thanks for listening
everybody god speed